so rec lens today we're going to do a
chip shot of him finishing up just
drying rack and to do that we have a
long travel jib the concept of a jib is
that it has the camera out front and
then it has a counterweight back here so
that allows you to push down on the
counterweight and fly the camera up into
the air so we put stuff like wedges that
Glenn uses to cut wood in here we put
spruce in here as well
but spruce is a really really light wood
so ultimately we found this giant moose
crack up at Glenn's place and we put it
in our basket and it's the perfect
counterbalance to our camera and the
amazing part is it even has handles
cool about negative 25 and the Kowalik
pop-tarts and sausages and we're rocking
it
know what time that is
mornin from north of the Arctic Circle
it's kind of a down day camp day trying
to get all of our all the crews gear
organized situated it's essential to
have the right gear essential to have
the right everything from your Footwear
to your tents to your stoves you know
and the personnel to be out here I mean
you're not going to sense to anybody out
in this field this is a tough
environment if you're any popular I
don't know doubtful
I think you hit off Robbi problem you
can probably hear it we have to have
pop-tarts no waiters no it's kind of
like coffee but on a different level we
want some of that
what I can't you got to share that right
now we got the a team out here
we're better what about 80 yards from
chip and actresses koala camp that's how
they actually live in the dead of winter
chip and Agnes have been coming up here
for 20 years
it's tough living a little bit for two
people in each articling
eight by eight we cook in there we sleep
in there have all the di t work with the
camera gear charging everything it's
it's not the easiest place to spread out
in but it's great beautiful look around
it's an amazing area to work in it's my
job it's my home base
you